let's take a look now at some of the top
races in our state and keep in mind
these are still unofficial
so democrat dina titus easily won
re-election over republican joyce
bentley
in nevada's first district that's
basically central clark county
to the second congressional district
that's up in northern and rural nevada
republican mark amade beat patricia
ackerman in that district
congressional district three between
incumbent democrats susie lee
and republican dan rodimer that is still
too close to call
and in congressional district four
democratic congressman stephen horsford
is still trying to hold that seat right
now with 50 percent of the vote
well many other local races are also
still too close to call right now let's
take a look at some of the big clark
county commission races here locally so
district c
razor thin still current las vegas city
councilman stavros anthony
and former secretary of state ross
miller are essentially tied
anthony is trying to become the first
republican on the clark county
commission since
bruce woodbury left back in 2009
all right let's take a look now at the
race for clark county school trustees
let's start with district a
lisa guzman has a 53 to 47 percent lead
over liberty leavitt
in district b vocal president trump
supporter katie williams does look
poised to beat jeff
profit evelyn garcia morales leads
tamika henry in district c
and it also appears school board
president lola brooks will keep her seat
she leads teacher alexis salt in
district e
8 news now is your local election
headquarters stay with us for the latest
results
you can also find them anytime on
8newsnow.com we'll have a bit more
coverage coming up here in just a few
minutes